[Musique]
bonjour cligner des yeux si vous pouvez
c'est très bien vous pourriez me dire
combien de doigts je vous montre 4 nous
sommes en quelle année on est en 2016
oui très bien et qui le président barack
obama qui j'ai réussi je suis passé
[Rires]
rien ne s'est passé comme je l'avais
imaginé je vous en prie elle m'était
mademoiselle azarova
c'est ici que j'ai vite nous avons
voyagé dans une autre dimension dans une
autre version de nous mêmes est-ce que
tu comprends que nous sommes au début de
quelque chose de vertigineux
ces deux là en retrait de son petit fin
je m'appelle karim washington je suis
détective privé je cherche une fille qui
a disparu elle vivait dans votre maison
c'est la personne qui disparaît on
dirait que vous avez vu un fantôme
cette photo m'a rappelé un jeune homme
que j'ai connue dans le michigan
tout est lié on a une chance d'y trouver
des réponses
tu es plus forte que tant de r d plus
gentil que tu m'as l'air
omer
rachel ce que tu es renata
bba les garçons
je t'ai demandé croire à des choses
impossibles à croire
et pas une fois tu ne m'a regardé comme
si j'étais dingue
tout ce qui entre ici
sans complètement barge on ne ressent
pas du tout il va falloir ouvrir les
yeux
je ne commencerai pas à toi c'est pas le
moment de jouer les courageuses c'est le
moment des chutes et toute cette beauté
cette énergie
qu'est ce qui la rend cohérente
qu'est-ce qui l'empêchent de n'être que
des sons en forme
lumières scène dans 5 4 3 2